bonjour à tous
mesdames et messieurs aujourd'hui j'ai
tenu à m'exprimer au plus tôt compte
tenu de l'extrême gravité des faits qui
ont été commis et de leur immense
retentissement car cette fois c'est tout
à la fois un enseignant qui a été
assassiné pour le travail qu'il avait
accompli mais c'est aussi la liberté de
pensée la liberté d'expression la
nécessité absolue de pour enseigner ces
principes fondamentaux dans nos écoles
qu'ils ont été atteints soutenu à
m'exprimer moins de 24 heures après ce
drame
c'est afin d'assurer dès à présent et
conformément prérogatives qui m'ont été
conférés par la loi
la diffusion d'une information la plus
objective possible
je tiens cependant à souligner que de
nombreuses investigations doivent être
encore réalisé afin de déterminer avec
précision les roulements les faits mais
aussi comment l'auteur a préparé son
crime et lequel éventuelle complicité
les pu bénéficier je veux aussi
souligner que ce crime terroriste et le
second commis pendant que se déroulent
les audiences du procès des attentats du
mois de janvier 2015 commencé au début
du mois de septembre dernier
cela confirme le très haut niveau de la
menace terroriste islamiste à laquelle
nous devons faire face s'agissant des
faits l'anc est menée sous l'autorité du
parquet antiterroriste qui s'est saisi
le 6 octobre à 18h30 a permis de
préciser lors des roulements leur
donnait 16 octobre à 7h11 la police
nationale a été sollicité par la police
municipale d'eragny sur oise à la suite
de la découverte d'un corps sur la voie
publique rue du buisson moineaux à
eragny la police municipale désigner un
homme porteur d'une arme de poing comme
auteur présumé des faits les policiers
nationaux identifiait ce dernier à
quelques centaines de mètres de la rue
roger salengro dans la même commune à
leur vue
la ville ducouret dans leur direction
retirant à cinq reprises avec une arme
de poing
trois policiers ripostait
ce qui entraîna la chute de la sai on
alors qu'il tentait de se relever de
donner des coups de couteau aux
policiers il était neutralisé par les
forces de l'ordre
son corps présente neuf impacts d'entrée
de balle d'un couteau le type poignard
une arme de poing le type airsoft et
cinq cartouches de gaz
compatible avec cette arme on est ici
lundi l'ue neutralisent était porteur
d'un titre de séjour délivré le 4 mars
dernier et valable jusqu'en mars 2030
au nom de abdul haq a bouilli dovic en
né le 12 mars 2002 à moscou en russie
intéressée de nationalité russe et
d'origine tchétchène bénéficier du
statut de réfugié et demeurait evreux
dans l'eure
il était inconnu des services de
renseignements sur un plan judiciaire il
n'a jamais été condamné
tout en étant connu pour des affaires de
dégradations de biens publics et de
violences en réunion
alors qu'il était encore mineur il
diatement après les faits un message de
revendication avait été postée sur un
compte twitter
nommé al ansar tchétchène deux cent
soixante dix accompagné d'une photo
macabre de la victime et du texte
suivant au nom d'allah le tout
miséricordieux le très miséricordieux de
abdullah lecentre dallas à maquereau le
dirigeant des infidèles
j'exécute et un de tes chiens de l'enfer
qui a osé rabaisser mohammad calme ses
semblables
avant que nous inflige induire châtiment
dans un tweet suivant le scripteur
désignait la victime par son nom les
investigations ont pu confirmer qu'il
s'agissait bien d'un compte appartenant
à l'auteur des faits la victime est un
professeur d'histoire géographie du
collège du bois d'aulne situe à conflans
sainte honorine à proximité immédiate du
lieu des faits d' et est âgé de 47 ans
cet enseignant se trouvait sur le chemin
le menant 2 sony travaille vers son
domicile
également situé à proximité lorsqu'il a
été attaqué avec une arme blanche
il présentait de multiples plaies à la
tête aux membres supérieurs et à
l'abdomen
il avait été décapité un second couteau
d'une longueur totale de 35 cm
ensanglanté était découvert une
trentaine de mètres
l'oni crime au regard de ces éléments et
compte tenu de la nature des faits du
contexte de leur réalisation du mode
opératoire et de la revendication le
parquet national anti terroriste s'est
saisi il ya ouvert une enquête de
flagrance des chefs d'assassinats en
relation avec une entreprise terroriste
d'association de malfaiteurs en vue de
commettre des crimes d'atteinte aux
personnes confiée conjointement à la
direction centrale de la police
judiciaire et à la direction générale de
la sécurité intérieure étant précisé que
la sous direction antiterroriste a été
désigné comme service quand d'amateurs
s'agissant du contexte à présent les
premières investigations ont permis
d'établir que début octobre
la victime avait lors d'un enseignement
l'instruction morale et civique
dispensés à une classe de 4e évoqué la
liberté d'expression thème s'inscrivant
dans le programme officiel de
l'éducation nationale un débat
habitations organisée autour de la
publication des caricatures de mahomet
par le journal satirique charlie hebdo
et de l'opportunité de leur publication
dès le 7 octobre au soir le père de
l'une des élèves publié sur son compte
facebook
un récit des faits faisant état de la
diffusion d'une image du prophète nu et
un appel à la mobilisation contre
l'enseignant en vue de son exclusion il
mentionnait aussi son propre numéro de
téléphone quelques minutes plus tard il
exhortait ses lecteurs à écrire au
collectif contre l'islamophobie en
france un inspection académique aux
milices
question nationale ou président la
république le 8 octobre en fin de
matinée le père de l'élève accompagné
d'un second individu se présentait au
collège du bois dole où il a été reçu
par la principale de l'établissement
celle-ci tenté en vain d'apaiser les
choses alors que les deux hommes exigé
avec virulence nous renvoie du
professeur sous peine mobilisation et
une manifestation le même jour en soirée
le même parents d'élèves publié à une
vidéo accompagnée d'un texte sur son
compte facebook dans laquelle il
désignait cette fois nommément le
professeur donner l'adresse du collège
et incitait je le cite à dire stop
un peu plus tard cet individu se
présenter au commissaire paul is de
conflans sainte honorine
à combien de sa fille afin de déposer
plainte pour diffusion d'image
pornographique dans son édition
cette jeune fille disait l'une des
caricatures parues dans le journal
charlie hebdo et indiqué que cet
enseignant préalablement à son exposé
avait demandé aux élèves musulmans
devaient la main et de sortir elle
précisait avoir été exclu deux joues à
la demande du professeur une enquête
était ouverte à la suite de cette
plainte et le 12 octobre
le professeur est entendue il décrivait
cette occasion le déroulé sont exposés
dont il remet et incopy il contestait
énergiquement avoir demandé aux élèves
musulmans de s'identifier et de sortir
de la classe
en revanche il précisait avoir pris soin
avant de montrer certains des dessins
concernés de proposer à ses élèves de ne
pas les regarder dans l'hypothèse où ils
pourraient être portés par ceux ci
faisant état de la vidéo publiée par le
père de l'élève
cet enseignant déposer plainte à son
tour du chef de diffamation publique
le support utilisé par le professeur
s'articulait autour des contours
il limite de la liberté d'expression ils
monteraient à titre d'exemple 2d
caricature publiée par charlie actes il
s'agissait pour la première de la une du
journal satirique
au lendemain de l'attentât du 7 janvier
2015 et pour la seconde d'un dessin
représentant le prophète ni la croupe y
légende et mahomet est une étoile est
née le 12 octobre
une seconde vidéo de 10 minutes intitulé
l'islam et le prophète insultée dans un
collège public était publiée sur youtube
le père de l'élève relaté à nouveau les
faits puis sa fille était interviewé par
un homme qui n'apparaît pas à l'écran et
confirmait ses déclarations livrées aux
policiers tierce personne précisait que
le président macron avait attisé la
haine vis-à-vis des vu cet homme
demandaient l'exclusion de
l'enseignement d'enseignants et
menaçaient de manifester devant le
collège d'inspection académique
il s'agissait de l'homme qui avait
accompagné l'eau père de l'élève au
collège lors du rendez vous avec la
principale le 8 octobre précédent la
principale du collège faisait d'ailleurs
état de nombreux appels menaçants reçu
par le collège à la suite de la
publication des vidéos du parent d'élève
certains parents d'élèves étaient reçus
ce qui permettait d'apaiser les tensions
à l'exception du père de la plaignante
qui refusait de rencontrer enseignants
elle précisait que le renvoi de sa fille
était indépendant de l'incident des
caricatures mais il y a des problèmes de
comportement qu'elle aux multiples
retards de la jeune fille comptait pour
le 14 octobre au commissariat le père et
sa fille ne se sont pas présentés sont
les premiers témoignages l'auteur des
faits se trouvait devant le collège
durant l'après midi il y avait sollicité
des élèves afin de lui désigner la
future victime
la première exploitation de son
téléphone saisie à proximité de son
corps a permis de retrouver dans le
bloc-notes le texte de la revendication
enregistre
à 12h17 ainsi que la photographie de la
victime décédée horodatées à 16h57
à ce stade des investigations
neuf personnes ont été interpellées et
placées en garde à vue quatre personnes
issues de l'entourage familial direct de
l'auteur des faits qui ont été placés en
garde à vue hier soir deux personnes
s'étant présentés spontanément hansson
soirée au commissariat d'evreux et qui
ont indiqué avoir été en contact avec
l'auteur peu avant les faits le père de
l'élève plaignante interpellé ce matin à
chanteloup les vignes est également
actuellement placé en garde à vue
faut préciser que la demi soeur de cet
homme avait rejoint à l'organisation
état islamique en 2014 en syrie et
qu'elle fait à ce titre l'objet d'un
mandat de recherche par un juge
d'instruction antiterroriste
enfin il n'y a personne actuellement
placé en garde à vue l'homme
apparaissant sur les vidéos publiées le
12 octobre ayant accompagné le père de
l'élève au collège ainsi que sa compagne
qui ont été interpellés ce matin à evry
cet homme est connu des services de
renseignement les investigations se
poursuivent maintenant est à présent aux
fins de préciser l'emploi du temps de
l'auteur dans les jours qui ont précédé
les faits elles ont également pour
finalité de déterminer le déroulement
exact du crime et enfin elles ont pour
objet d'établir l'application les
personnes gardées à vue ainsi que de
toute autre personne en plus ou
impliqués à un titre ou à un autre dans
les faits mesdames et messieurs je vous
remercie de votre attention je ne
répondrai pas à des questions
aujourd'hui qui pourrait être posée
compte tenu de la lecture très récent
des faits qui ne me permet pas d'avancer
plus en amont en avant sous peine de
risquer de nuire à ses investigations
je vous remercie encore au revoir